[Musique]
interview
super exclu n'es-tu pas tu es jeff
goldblum la star de cinéma en fait
oui c'est vrai je suis jeff goldblum
bien sympa sympa de te voir si euh
tu sais je te connais mais euh si tu l'étais
si tu devais présenter  toi à
quelqu'un ici en france euh quelqu'un dans un
club ou quelque chose comme ça que
dirais-tu euh que dirais-tu que dirais-
tu quelqu'un qui ne te connaît pas
que dirais-tu
euh euh je dirais je suis je suis euh
jeff goldblum des états-unis je suis
un acteur j'ai fait un tas de
films peut-être que vous m'avez vu à la volée je
pense que c'était le plus
populaire ici et en fait je vais être
dans un
dans un film à venir  bientôt appelé mr
frost
avec euh alan bates et kathy baker eh bien
c'était euh
difficile de devenir une star
à hollywood ou avez-vous comment
c'est arrivé était-ce difficile
je suis allé à new york après avoir grandi
à pittsburgh en pennsylvanie
et j'ai étudié dans une grande école de théâtre, mais
très peu de temps après avoir obtenu mon diplôme
presque un an, j'avais 18 19  je suis tombé dans
un travail au théâtre et j'ai fait quelques
pièces, puis
robert altman m'a vu dans une pièce de théâtre à
new york et m'a demandé de faire un
split en californie et j'ai fait nashville
et une chose en a conduit une autre alors je l'ai
gardé
continué à travailler et euh et et en fait je n'ai jamais
eu à avoir un travail direct tu sais hey
t'es-tu déjà senti comme euh après avoir fait
le vol t'es-tu déjà senti
comme
ce personnage euh du tout
je non je ne le fais pas  se sentir comme la la
mouche bien que ce personnage vous savez
ce qui m'a plu à propos de ce personnage
était qu'il était
romantique et héroïque et euh j'avais une partie
passionnée et poétique de moi-même et
euh
et et et j'ai l'impression que parfois
me parler de mr  frost à propos de votre nouveau
film mr frost
euh oh c'est un film très euh
intéressant vous savez je je c'est avec
euh comme j'ai mentionné kathy
baker et alan bates je suis un mystérieux
et dangereux et charmant personnage séduisant et
imprévisible et
spontané qui fait une très sorte de
contact intime avec  kathy baker et
et et d'un côté la détruit
mais d'un autre côté
[Music] l'
ouvre et
c'est une sorte d'
histoire d'amour violente et dangereuse quel est le que diriez-vous
sont les trois
meilleurs réalisateurs avec lesquels vous avez travaillé
oh je  j'ai eu beaucoup de chance j'ai travaillé
avec beaucoup de
gens formidables j'ai travaillé avec mon petit
partenaire woody allen en mouvement j'ai travaillé
avec paul mazurski et robert altman et
philip kaufman et lawrence kasden
et beaucoup de grands réalisateurs philippe a dit
os
dirigé mr  frost et il était merveilleux
je vais vous dire que j'ai passé autant de temps à
faire mr frost que j'en ai eu
sur n'importe quel film quel est votre meilleur film de tous les temps
j'aime le plus les dernières choses que
j'ai faites j'ai  un sentiment particulièrement bon à
propos de mr grenouille
et le pire que je n'ai jamais fait euh
un film que je regarde maintenant et je suis
vraiment c'est vrai tourmenté à propos de
j'aurais aimé ne pas l'avoir fait je
sais que tu as  euh que tu vas
que tu as été en thérapie parfois est-
ce
que ça aide en tant qu'acteur  du tout, agir
est une étrange
combinaison de mentir et de dire la
vérité,
c'est vraiment mentir parce que les
circonstances, vous savez
ce que vous dites, vous faites qui vous
dites que vous êtes et les circonstances
sont inventées, c'est un mensonge,
mais pour rendre cela crédible à  faites
comme si c'était la vraie vie,
vous devez être honnête d'une autre
manière, vous devez
être vous-même d'une certaine manière, même si cela
peut être un saut d'imagination,
vous devez être vous-même, donc une thérapie
ou quelque chose de thérapeutique qui
vous éduque.  vous-même et vous permet de
vous connaître et d'être capable de dire
la vérité en fait
et de vous rendre plus véridique plus
authentique moins faux d'une certaine manière
euh plus en contact avec les choses qui
signifient
quelque chose pour vous et plus en contact avec
vos sentiments
le mieux c'est  acteur que vous êtes avez-
vous admiré quelqu'un quand vous étiez enfant
oh c'est la première chose qui me vient
à l'esprit, c'est que j'avais
un frère aîné nommé rick qui avait quatre
ans de plus que moi
et euh en fa  ct malheureusement quand il avait 23 ans,
il est mort et j'avais 19 ans. tu sais mais il était moi
je l'ai admiré
et la façon dont il était tu sais je veux dire il a
commencé à sortir avec des filles tu sais
quand j'étais encore un peu trop jeune aussi
et je je l'ai vraiment admiré et
qu'est-ce que tu te dis tous les
matins quand tu me vois dans le miroir
je chante tu sais ce matin je pense juste
ce matin j'ai
chanté j'ai chanté un pot-
pourri de chansons un pot-pourri de chansons euh c'est la vie  était l'une
des chansons
et et hé regardez-moi avec l'une des
chansons
[Musique]
bleu